alors cette ce meuble a aussi eu une
histoire c'est un meuble tout à fait
intéressant d'abord il faut préciser que
ce meuble fait partie des premières
acquisitions du musée dans les années 70
à l'époque où ce musée a été créé et il
provient effectivement du mobilier de la
famille car il faut savoir qu'à l'époque
lorsqu'on a voulu la création de ce
musée un musée représente et concerne
des collections le musée n'avait pas de
collections et le Conseil général s'est
porté acquéreur d'un ensemble de meubles
ayant appartenu à la famille alors c'est
une c'est une commode une commode tout à
fait intéressante car on le connaît un
petit peu son histoire toujours grâce au
livre écrit au journal écrit par Henri
Colin pendant des bassins c'est une
commode qui n'est pas de fabrication
locale alors cette commode elle est pure
style le style Louis XVI le style Louis
XVI qui se caractérise par une grande
sobriété vous voyez que cette commode
très rectiligne il n'y a pratiquement
pas de courbe et le style Louis XVI
apparaît à l'époque de Louis XVI donc
dans les années 1770 et tout cet intérêt
c'est effectivement cette l'influence de
l'antiquité car il faut savoir que au
début du 18e siècle on va découvrir deux
villes enfouies de l'huile romaine et
Pompéi ou on va découvrir justement des
ensembles mobiliers des peintures tout
un art de la grande époque de Rome qui
va donc inspirer tous les décorateurs
qui m'inspirer les artistes et cette
commode justement retrouve un petit peu
la pureté classique de la grande Rome la
commode est très très simple c'est très
classique on ne peut plus classique la
seule fantaisie vous le voyez c'est
l'usage effectivement du bronze qui
souligne un petit peu chaque tiroir
puisque c'est une commode à trois
tiroirs
et le côté très géométrique également
des poignets vous voyez que là on
n'utilise pas la courbe pour les
poignets mais c'est vraiment un motif
beaucoup plus géométrique tout à fait
caractéristique de ce style Louis XVI
alors l'originalité de cette commode
c'est que effectivement on a
l'impression d'un bois Nord c'est de la
cajou en fait mais c'est à cajou est
utilisé en placard c'est-à-dire que à
l'intérieur la structure du meuble et
sans doute en chaîne ou en être qui
n'étaient pas vraiment des bois
considérés comme des bois nobles et on a
voulu donner un côté beaucoup plus
luxueux à ce meuble en appliquant de
l'acajou sur toutes les sur tous les
côtés de ce meuble d'autre part on voit
que la partie supérieure le plateau est
en marbre donc c'est aussi le marbre est
une matière noble et puis ça veut aussi
un côté pratique parce que justement la
commode c'était un objet que l'on
utilisait on posait des objets et le
marbre résistait mieux bien entendu que
le bois qui pouvait être rayé si on
posait un peu trop violemment les objets
dessus
donc cette commande a été ramenée dans
dans des colis par Henri Pollin des
bassins au cours de son second voyage et
c'est vraiment des pièces très
importantes pour le musée car cette
commode il faut imaginer qu'elle se
trouvait là autant de Madame des bassins
puisque ici nous trouvons dans la
chambre de Madame dépassant et que dans
la famille on a conservé effectivement
la l'emplacement de cette commode de
génération en génération